each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
okay so without further ado the last
talk is about giving away stuff right
that's it's the free thing right at the
the reason you've hung around and waited
for but this is a this is Darren green
who's going to be giving our last talk
Darren is heading up our Asher for
research program and he's going to talk
to you about how you can use the cloud
for your research and beyond actually
I'm going to do a range of things well
thank you Chris I'm going to cover a
range of different subjects I've got
about 150 six slides now I haven't
you've you've SAT through a lot so this
will be a little bit lighter than some
of the other presentations not that
there was anything wrong with you the
presentations but what I wanted to do is
explain to you a little bit about the
umbrella activity that I lead with dan
Fay who's chosen always there he is
there so dan dan actually leads the
azure for research initiative I helped
him with that and you're part of it
whether you realize that or not the fact
that you're here means you're part of
the usual for research initiative and
you will have seen some of the imagery
that we use for this this is a sticker
that we've just created and the idea is
were the little lab coat wearing
scientists and we benefit from and the
personification of our cloud is this
giant robot that does the number
crunching for you and the reason why I
want to start with this is to share with
you a very personal experience that I've
had with the cloud because when we
started out on this journey which is
about I know eight or nine months ago
that we we danced nodding so he approves
of me saying eight or nine months which
is good so eight and nine months ago we
started out and actually put a plan
together for helping researchers
understand what it means to use our
cloud computing infrastructure because
it was originally built as you've heard
for a different purpose okay a lot of
the training material lot of the content
one of the examples that we were talking
to people about was very business
specific and we knew that that didn't
work didn't make it accessible to
researchers so so here's a pitch for my
kids
why am i showing me a picture of my kids
this is been on the left this is jack on
the right they got to hear about the
fact that I was working with cloud
computing they heard about cloud
computing didn't really know what it was
so they asked me to explain I said look
it's you know it's a little bit like the
computers that you currently have access
to at home you play games on Berk you're
sort of logging in remotely and it's not
just one computer you can scale up to a
vast array of computers okay so I've
been explaining cloud computing to them
for some time I went off to a conference
and at this conference there were I'm
hoping none of you were at this
particular conference there are about 76
computing services head so these are the
people that run computing services in
universities in North America all right
this was back in 2013 and I was talking
as part of a panel discussion about the
way in which the cloud is used by
researchers and many of them were saying
oh no no you know we don't really need
the cloud our researchers don't use the
cloud they have no intention of using
the cloud and in nearly every case they
the universities were using the cloud
their researchers were using the cloud
okay and in some cases there were very
heavy users of our cloud all right we
came as a surprise to them and for many
was quite disruptive okay because
suddenly they went from being the
gatekeepers to computing to being sort
of disintermediated the researchers
could get a grant go straight onto you
no assurance just start spinning up
machines and getting work done and that
made them feel a little bit strange you
know what's that role it's a little bit
like libraries that used to be the
gatekeepers to the sacred texts well now
they have a very different function
about curating digital assets or
discovering digital assets so what I
came home I came home from this
particular conference and we're saying
look these guys don't know what's going
to hit them okay computing is changing
as a paradigm shift and my kids were
saying what do you mean I said look that
some of them were anxious
okay great sense of anxiety their loss
of status okay loss of control loss of
influence that are outdated they feel
threatened and what I was saying to my
kids was what they should see is that
actually there's some freedom that they
can get from this they don't need to be
trying to deliver stuff the same sort of
stuff that we're doing before and
actually it's an opportunity then for it
to innovate they need to change the
nature of the services that they're
providing to the folks in their
universities or in their computing
communities research communities little
did I know how this would come back to
haunt me these guys then said okay
that's fine that's great can we play
with the cloud I couldn't think of a
good reason why not I've given them
access to computing infrastructure
before so I said okay fine I then showed
them if you haven't already logged into
as your hopefully will do at some point
in the next few days or weeks I then
showed them had how to log into the
management port I didn't give them the
password all right but I then you know I
logged in and then showed them look this
is how you spin things up this is how
you get attached storage to a virtual
machine that you've created you see how
you do an endpoint and then they said
okay dad we got it which is sort of code
for just leave us alone get out of it
you know we know what we're doing and I
said but no lonely no okay sure
enough I realized at that point that I
really represent two things for them I'm
money and technology and that's it all
right and they've just gotten access to
some more technology and they wanted to
be left alone okay fine about an hour
later this is what the screen cap looked
like and for those of you that know sure
you'll recognize most of the dashboard
you'll see that they've got a storage
account at the top you go they've got a
couple of min kragh and you've spoiled
it already minecraft all right they've
got minecraft running
and okay fair play to them they're you
know pretty good and sure enough you
know this is a fairly recent plot and
I'll explain a little bit more of the
sort of stuff that they're doing and
yeah they've split up I think originally
they just had a single CPU instance
that's all they needed for the two of
them sort of play okay at least that's
what they did for the first day or two
all right and actually i felt quite good
about this because I'd been I'd had a
little time little pc that I'd been
using to run Minecraft at home within
the house all right and I was doing the
patches I was doing the server updates I
was doing performance monitoring they'd
be complaining about latency every now
and then and go and have a look if
something was going wrong if I could
stop something screaming so that they
could have a better gaming experience
and every now and then I took the
firewall down so that people could
actually play on the same server so
friends that were local complain and it
was you know is it out quite an overhead
for me to have to do that okay so I was
quite pleased that not having to do this
stuff they were really pleased because
hey they're running in one process but
they can scale it up if they wanted to
they were doing data sharing so they
were both putting files onto the is your
server and then sort of working on them
they were having shared experiences as I
would find with their friends and
actually they started collaborating and
innovating within just a couple of days
in ways that I'd never imagined and I
want to show you what they were doing so
they were given an assignment this is
totally unrelated all right they just
had this assignment where they have to
work together as part of a team to
design a space station explain the
function of the different parts of the
space station and how they arrived at
the overall design so they came back
saying hey we've got this assignment
that we've got it who came down from
schools have got this assignment great
they ran upstairs started beavering away
and there for about 10 or 15 minutes I
wandered by the bottom of the stairs and
I can hear minecraft noises all right so
guess what they've done they'd opened up
the minecraft server to the group of
friends
and they were using the instant
messaging in mindset minecraft to
coordinate the different bits of the
space station they were then screen
capping like this screen capturing and
pasting it into PowerPoint and they were
putting a narrative and notes onto the
design points and they were doing this
they were flying into a walking into
different parts of this and then taking
the screen caps all right this is what
they did when I gave them access to the
cloud all right so from my perspective I
then went through all of these things
anxiety losses data loss of control all
right that's not what I expected them to
do with it okay I was the one that
provided IT to them all right that was
my function now I'm just the source of
money and nothing else all right and I
actually literally I went straight I
know you can't I was you know and then I
realized I stopped myself was repeating
exactly you know the sort of paradigm
shift that was threatening the folks at
the universities delivering competing
I've got this with my own family all
right so what do I have to do well I it
gives me some freedom I have to find
other ways of innovating i'll come back
to her okay all right so that's a sort
of very personal experience here's the
magic though here's the real magic I
think I never give my kids kids access
to a supercomputer at least I wouldn't
have thought of they never get access to
a supercomputer but the cloud gives them
that exactly the same infrastructure and
fabric we've used for running 20,000
compute cause to analyze you know
billions of pairs of genetic markers so
this is work by david hackman's team as
part of this sort of research that tony
is in charge of so this is just one
example there are other examples that
you've heard over the past couple of
days but for me there's something
profound happening when my kids can use
the same infrastructure that can do this
type of research okay and that's a
fundamental change they'd never get at
NSF grant it never get it do he grant or
maybe not for a few years at least but
they're already running on the same
infrastructure pretty pretty remarkable
all right so what are the implicit
asians of this and they go obviously
much deeper than the sort of time that
my kids can spend playing Minecraft
though there any this speaks a little
bit to some of the issues are comments
that we're wrestling with before and
talking about over lunch of the way that
the cloud can even ultimately change the
economics of the way that science is
done so imagine for a moment you get a
proposal approved you you might have to
go through some recruitment depending on
whether you've got you know people new
people resources available but actually
pretty quickly if you do have people in
place you can deploy a community your
own research group virtual machine in
the cloud you can extend your models you
can do whatever simulation work our
analysis that you want and then
simultaneously you can do the following
things and again this is pretty much a
uniquely enabled by the cloud you can
publish your paper you can publish the
virtual machine the software stack that
you used interaction to conduct the
research you can publish it in a note
mayor can publish it in a restricted way
to your community you can publish the
data although people can reproduce your
results the scientific method actually
is more enabled by the cloud without
this sort of approach you're begging to
get access to people software are you
begging to be given access to their data
can i have your day you know the paper
may have been published but as funding
agencies insist that the data generated
from research that's funded by the
public purse be made available the cloud
actually gives us a mechanism for doing
that and then perhaps the most
controversial in this is then this
relates to a sort of positioning paper
that dan Reed Dennis and I rode with
Elizabeth Grossman who's one of our
policy folks here in Microsoft we were
asserting that actually allows the
opportunity for researchers to create a
marketplace okay for their data or their
research services to be
cured okay what do we mean me what do we
mean by that we mean that industry
actually can discover these published
virtual machines or some of the exposed
data and then say okay could you run
that analysis but on our data set which
is also in the cloud so it gives an
opportunity for researchers to offer
different services and those services
could be real range of different levels
okay so it could be that you've got some
run type special runtime or database
services that you do some special data
management or application services or
that you're going to provide some just
some fundamental research if you give us
access to your data whatever the
commercial companies we will do some
analysis so in the same way that you can
publish your capabilities here to the
research community you can actually
create a marketplace or you can be
active in a marketplace where you expose
some of these two commercial customers
why would you want to do that will you
generate an additional revenue stream
okay maybe fold that's some of that back
into your core research activities okay
so with a lot of this in mind we put
together the usual for research
initiative okay and what we're doing is
really a range of different things we're
providing free access to cloud computing
we're offering the training that some of
you probably did at the beginning of the
week and we're providing some technical
resources and I'll mention some of those
and some support capabilities okay so
I'm going to step you through some of
the things that we're doing there the
first one of this these is the training
we've just we've just finished the last
quarter or so we've done 14 training
events we've got another 14 scheduled to
the end of q4 that takes us up to pretty
much to the end of the year if you're
interested in hosting training let us
know Dennis will guarantee that we'll
deliver it at your university
no we can't guarantee that we can
deliver it at your honor University no
we are interested in knowing though if
you're if you think this the training
that you've done this week or if you
think if you have even not aware of the
sort of details of the trading we can
take you through that if you think it's
going to be useful to locally at your
universities you can see where we're
already we've already deployed and the
schedule ones are in this sort of beige
ish color so that was the training the
other sort of key thing that we're
offering if you're not already aware is
the awards this isn't money that we give
you this is access time on ashore these
are these are as your passes that last
for a year they're worth about 180,000
core hours approximately 20 terabytes of
data that's roughly the sort of
footprint you could use that a vacation
more quickly than a year if you did
would probably ask you what you were
doing not not in a negative way like
what are we doing or what were you
thinking but in a hang what were you
doing all right how can you how can you
use this so quickly because you know
we're just interested in in what the
workloads that you're finding work
really well okay and typically what
we're doing if people do consume their
allocation more quickly than a year is
yeah we're asked the question what
you're doing and then we'll probably
just grant you another allocation if
there's something that you need to
complete all right so we're very
flexible and right at the moment then
it's correct me if I'm wrong but we have
no hard limits on those allocations okay
even on the number of allegations no I
mean on the the footprint that we're
granting to people yes yeah okay we are
we are okay so what does it mean to
actually apply to one of these this is
pretty much it the application process
is pretty much what's on this slide here
so you should be able to answer all of
these fields if you can't don't apply
all right but it's things like name all
right position title
the hardest thing you have to do is we
want little abstract and then a proposal
no more than three pages we struggle to
stay awake if it's longer than free but
now three pages is usually enough for us
to get a handle on what it is that
you're proposing ok so the relatively
short relatively lightweight things we
take submissions every two months so on
the fifteenth that's the middle of all
even months all right so we we do
actually if you if you submit before the
15th we will take a look at it but you
sort of don't be wanting to submit
online the 17th of the 19th of the even
months because you'll have to wait a
couple of months okay so typically we
take proposals every we evaluate them
every two months we've granted 183
projects covering 28 countries and you
see the geographical distribution there
in glorious pie chart on the right hand
side there's nothing geopolitical in
these allocations so don't read into
this that we have any particular you
know desire to not invest in Germany
that's just that we haven't had as many
proposals from Germany there's a little
bit of an artifact of you see wow that's
quite a few from Brazil okay so why is
that well we did the training in Brazil
as one of the first places so we get a
lot more you know we've got more
proposals coming in from Brazil and yes
so you know if you don't see your
country represented there then sticking
a proposal as well as these every two
months this evaluations that we do we
have some special calls there are some
things that were sort of particularly
interested in receiving proposals for we
recently had one that was calling for
virtual machine so a virtual machine
that may be relevant for your community
then we were particularly interested in
you know would you develop those and
then publish them we also did one in
conjunction with the White House on
analysis of climate data we're going to
do a very specific RFP for Brazil so we
did our original training six seven
months ago we're about to go back into
another round of training and we're
going to have a call shortly for matlab
use on the drill but I'll come to that
in a second yeah we we've got a major
event coming up in the summer in Russia
some of you may be involved in that but
we're also open to suggestions or
proposals if there's other things that
you think we should be asking for here
if there are other events that you think
we should be creating to help us
understand the way that researchers want
to be using is riven just let us know
okay pretty much hi oh we should have a
Python call high five high five
good suggestion
okay so those are the notes the research
world so delving in a little bit deeper
by discipline I wonder what we should do
this sort of analysis that Jeffrey's
been doing on the the nature of the
application and you know using some of
the taxonomy that you've got but this is
just by discipline I'm rather
disappointed by the chemistry showing
given that my PhDs in chemical physics
so that is disappointing lot from
computer science and then digging into
this segment here you see that it
there's this there's quite a long tail
but machine learning big data analytics
that sort of stuff not that these are
necessarily completely distinct but it
gives us some sense of the sort of
workloads that people are targeting in
here and I think then is correct me if
I'm wrong which you probably will a lot
of the things that we're seeing in the
computer science is where there's a
computer scientist working alongside
another say yes I got that one right
thank you good area is usually a bio
person in charge of working in computer
science prison and that's why Janelle
makes looks smaller because it's all
classified to fire okay okay I'm not
going to go through these some of these
you've actually had some in-depth
presentations on but this is just a
little bit of a sample I don't think
Harrison Ford is actually one of the pis
though
he did posed for the photo which was
rather good yeah excellent all right so
two common requests that we've we've
received it and this is responding to
the request that we've been so from some
of the training event from some of the
RFP winners we get questions I ok why do
you have matlab running in the cloud and
how do you help me do just really simple
parametric sweeps so here are sort of
our these are our responses so the first
one of is as making sure that MATLAB
discrete computing server is working on
as your and this is just the graphic to
support that claim to use this you need
to have a matlab client alright need to
have a license to a matlab client okay
and then you can then schedule on to a
windows HPC server from which you can
then provision additional resources up
in the cloud ok we've just gone through
the process of agreeing the licenses
that we own for this side so we provide
the licenses on this side ok you need to
come with lice you know the licenses for
the client at this site though that you
have haven't dcs license on the client
you have to have you have to have it on
this side no but what kind of what kind
of a licensed PI and only you just need
the clients license we provide the
distributed computing server licenses
yeah the academic you just have to have
an academic version of malla that's all
you have and I mathworks will activate
it for you verify that your user and
we're working with Matt Matt works on us
okay so all right definitely we know
there's going to follow up for this and
what we're looking for is actually and
this isn't broadly announced okay so
most likely from the constituents in
this room we will fully populate the
roughly five sort of early adopters so
we're looking for a few folks to help
they're familiar with matlab that have
workload that they'd like to push up
into a jour if you're one of those
people and already you've probably
noticed that when ring is active on this
then this is the email and just put as
your title matlab pilot or just talked
to him before he escapes at the back of
the room okay we will once we've ironed
out this all right once we vine we've
had those early adopters sort of working
and checking that things are behaving in
the way that we want we will have an RFP
that more broadly invites people to
propose workloads using this okay but we
don't want to open it up to a large
number until we find out all the
problems so there may be problems we
need whoever those early adopters are to
be a little bit sympathetic that you
know things may not be perfect on day
one yeah we're not coming in with
nothing so so this is the first of a
64-page good okay- graphics is about 20
pages it's on the technical paper
section of a drawer for research website
okay
so this is something when rings been
authoring to help people get started it
explains exactly how you set all of this
up okay so that was the first the first
thing that was sort of announce it were
announcing we're quietly announcing that
we'd like you to engage with us on the
next one is something that we've
codenamed internally simulation runner
okay and it allows us to do really just
a scale out of an existing some existing
sort of contained application this could
be Python it could be an XE it might be
the matlab runtime or some other program
that you've got and the way that this
works is and you can you an are at the
animation if you like this is this is
when wings handiwork it looks hideous
from here I have to say oh no it looks
good from here but standing right there
everything's out of shape so so so what
when ring is built is effectively a
portal from which you can define the
nature of the parametric sweep that you
wish to do you have on your clients or
end user the ability to point it at a
particular application which could be in
dropbox it might be on some local
storage or it could be on some of your
storage the portal effectively defines
the Q the Q then gets cranked through
and then sort of delivers you can
monitor the activities and you'll see
the status effectively the status of the
workload it's a relatively simple
infrastructure but we know it's a very
common request for the sort of
pleasingly parallel some of the
pleasingly parallel word man
it was half the jobs it's half the jobs
you can understand it's a very common
request for us so rather than have
everybody instantiate the same sort of
scripts what can we do to help yes it
was yeah okay lovely animation alright
so again what we're looking for is some
early adopters bisa Isaac but I call it
embarrassingly parallel okay pleasingly
parallels a little bit more
sophisticated as somebody that used to
paralyze CFD computational chemistry
codes finite element codes these sorts
of things but i would get embarrassed
about claiming that i paralyze them so
so and it you probably already know the
sort of workload but you know it's it's
image processing we've got vast array of
images that you wish to analyze or some
design optimization where you're
changing some of the parameters on the
design and want to go through maybe a
full simulation or optimization on each
one again wen Ming dot m sdn @ live.com
slightly different title though
simulation run a pilot okay previous one
was matlab you could put simulation
runner and you can see a little bit of
the screencap of the some simulation
runner itself okay some other things
that we've been that have been requested
others are technical examples design
patterns these sorts of things that are
relevant to research if we remember I
said that a lot of the previous examples
are great if you're in business or what
have you got for researchers we've got
technical papers other people have been
asking for okay that's fine how do I get
data in I've got these devices or want
to build devices and I want to spray
data up into the cloud how can I do that
so we've been working on these two if
you were to go online at sure for
research calm right now you will see
that we have technical papers on each of
these topics so there's some early
overview just to get people started and
then we get in a little bit more detail
but more sophisticated as we go through
so HBC and technical computing scaling a
cloud service installing blast
using things like the service bus and
Peyton okay if there are gaps if you say
that's all very well but you know I
really need to do this you don't have
anything that explains how you know how
I achieve this particular action let us
know okay these were ones that we
thought just from the initial feedback
made sense but if those are the things
that you think you should be doing
please give us the feedback and we'll
sort of SDN enabled part of the mic
either the I you or my research groups
yet compute infrastructure i'm hoping i
think i'm rocking useful like paper yep
how you scale out from on-premise have
you was the cloud bursting or whatever
you want to call it yep these are
provider and just have it conveniently
linkedin using these remarks of nice
little value Group OS the end RDMA and
things like them interesting ideas yep
should you hear folks at the back so
okay so yeah I know you know I just I'll
just in case they want to comment so
Jeffrey's request was could we have one
that explains how to burst out from
local premise you know in you know on a
university campus for a new department
open to the time yep
yes other things that we're that we can
do so we are also we can also give other
sort of technical help on if there are
architectural issues that you have or if
there are particular code samples that
would be useful please let us know I've
mentioned the simulation runner early
adopters or beta testers if you have it
if you're having technical problems then
we have a support email that you can use
so this is where we have a third party
that will help solve technical problems
we work alongside them they just helped
us deal with some you know if sort of
sort of volume issues so that's a useful
email to sort of note down it's not at
microsoft com okay this is a third party
that we've commissioned to help us and
to some of the sort of technical
problems and if you if you do plan on
putting a proposal in feel free to
contact us the the sort of central
contact email is on the web if you've
got a preferred member of the team here
feel free to email them and they'll work
with you on helping tomb the proposal
okay okay so what I want to mention now
is is a conversation that actually we
have I have relatively frequently about
how you can build your own devices and
get them to communicate with the cloud
and this is going to bring me back to to
where I started out a little bit so I
want to introduce to you something
called dotnet gadget here and there's a
little box of tricks that I've got back
here which is actually one of the dotnet
gadgeteer kits and just to give you a
sense those look very big when they're
projected on there so where is it this
board here is is this so what we had
found this is predominately driven by
the researchers in Microsoft Research
Cambridge who were trying to innovate by
constructing lots of different devices
okay and they they build things like
cameras that would take photographs
intermittently and recorder the data in
that in the to record a day in a life of
well a day in the life of somebody that
maybe has memory problems and by
reviewing information about the day at
the end of the day it would refresh
their memory such that they could
actually recall things over a long long
time period much more successfully so
this was steve Hodges in his research
team myself research cambridge that was
one device and then there were other
devices that they wanted to maybe do
with the types of sensing in the home
setting and they realized that they're
having to create from scratch pretty
much the sort of base components and
they said look this is silly let's go to
some of the hardware manufacturers and
get them to build boards which we can
just plug are the devices into and
that's what spawned the jet at the
gadget gadgeteer project it's programmed
from visual studio uses the dotnet micro
framework you can program in Visual
Basic you can program in C sharp if you
wish and it doesn't look particularly
elegant that's the same board here with
a range of different devices clustered
round it this is a little LCD
touchscreen okay this is an SD card
holder there are some LEDs there's
buttons as a joystick there a camera
there's an Ethernet port there that's
how you power the thing it can be a
little battery pack or it can go into a
USB and really it's an incredibly
flexible way of constructing sensing
temperature sensors are sort of standard
issue for these things temperature
humidity you can have soil humidity
sensors there are hundreds of different
devices now that have been produced for
this and this is the sort of thing that
you can go from having nothing or you
know the kit in in the form that is here
just in the box to something working
within just a couple of hours okay
there's no soldering required you just
plug it together you can get bluetooth
interfaces you can get
what else we've got Wi-Fi connectivity
so you could have something relatively
simple low power you can get GPRS as
well yeah so so it will connect to the
cell phone network so relatively simple
easy to construct and deploy and then
send information back to you or back up
into the cloud alright I won't go I've
mentioned a lot of the stuff that's on
here this is just one example I built
this well the visual studio built this
this is me constructing an FM radio this
is the FM radio module I then put on an
infrared receiver and have a little key
fob which is here that I used for tuning
it I didn't bother putting on or I did
put the display on actually so that's
the back of the display and by pressing
up down you can tune the radio on the
display it would tell you which station
you listen to which song track see the
volume this is it actually constructed
you can see it's listening to channel
94.9 this is actually in a hotel in
Moscow and I went over and was building
this on the flight which brings me to a
note of caution about the way that the
crew of Airlines view that sort of
electronics and they get rather anxious
because you know they don't know what
it's doing and you look very suspicious
and and there's conflict going on in the
Ukraine in Ukraine and they start
talking about strapping your hands to
the arms of the chair all right so but
other than in flight it's a really good
idea to get one of these kits and start
programming and playing around which
brings me back to these guys because you
can guess what they want to do perhaps
they want to take one of these kits work
with that
of people on the top right and we
produce something that Kenji's
colleagues didn't kenji was part of
we're in this case this is a windows
mobile phone sent up on a weather
balloon so it's a eighty ninety thousand
feet something of that magnitude so
Kendra is very gracefully came and gave
a presentation to these these Boy Scouts
and sort of inspired them now this won't
be sending back data to as you're all
right because there's no network up
there that they're going to be sort of
in communication with but it sort of
brings us full circle onto the sort of
ways in which people can now build
devices do so they can be recording
scientific data as this thing goes up
there going to be analyzing it get when
it gets back but we're just at the start
it's it's now commodity electronics that
you can use to do scientific data
collection and these guys have access to
the cloud as well alright this is just
one sense that they're going to be
sending up but you can bet your life
that within six or nine months they're
going to be thinking about okay what
else could we be doing they've already
been talking about the fact what if they
got a few more kids and package them up
and threw them into Puget Sound all
right and let them sort of float up and
down they can look at the patterns
they'll get signals back every so often
all right if we can see a network
because if the Wi-Fi cards and scan for
open networks that actual network pump
some data back okay so all right so
that's that then gets you to the problem
okay how are you going to get all this
data back from multiple devices there's
the service bus infrastructure that we
have within ashore but I want to talk to
a little bit about another project that
we have for managing you hear about the
Internet of Things well we have a
project called the lab of things and I'm
going to play you a short video that
explains that and hopefully the volume
is going to be high enough you may need
to be quiet
lab of things is a flexible platform for
research that uses connected devices
meet Albert a researcher who builds and
deploys connected devices into people's
homes researchers like Albert work in
many different domains including
healthcare energy management and home
automation when albert wants to conduct
a research study he needs an easy way to
deploy his connected devices into a
large number of houses ideally
geographically dispersed around the
world to simplify deploying sensors and
devices into homes Albert installs a
home hub a windows computer running the
home OS software the home hub supports
discovery and set up of several
different types of devices including
z-wave devices IP cameras and custom
devices built using microsoft.net
Gadgeteer Albert can extend home OS to
work with other devices as needed by
writing simple drivers for example if
Albert wants to study a new sensor he
invented that detects when people fall
in the house he writes a driver and then
a small application to connect to the
lab of things platform he can then
easily store data in the cloud remotely
update his study if he finds a problem
and monitor the status of his
deployments across many different homes
Marie is another scientist studying
Aging in Place like Albert she uses lab
of things to deploy sensors in many
homes that she can easily monitor Marie
realizes that she and Albert have
recruited similar participants in
different locations because they are
both using lab of things Albert can
deploy his study into houses Marie has
recruited and Marie can deploy her study
into some of Albert's houses lab of
things enables researchers to share data
code and participants lowering the
barrier to evaluating ideas in a diverse
range of settings
so the one caveat i'd make to that is it
sort of implies that you're deploying
globally and you're collecting data over
national boundaries I'm not quite sure
that that's a lot of that happening but
just from a very common scenarios one in
which people wish to deploy sensors in
houses in a particular you know a
particular cohort another part of maybe
the US people also want to deploy and
then you realize you've recruited this
roughly the same type of people and you
want to be able to increase your your
number of locations and if you've set it
up using the lab of things and the sort
of software fabric that we've got you
can easily deploy and monitor okay so
it's a very very common problem that
we've seen that people without this this
sort of middleware have had it had to
sort of regenerate or recode create
drivers maintain a whole load of
software so if you have an
infrastructure or if you have an intent
to deploy sensors anywhere then have a
look at the type of things as something
that really accelerate accelerate you
through that process all right just get
back
and you can obviously type level things
into your favorite search engine or Bing
and or you can you can have a look at
one of these web links if you've got any
comments or any questions then just
contact lab of things at microsoft com
and it will be routed into our research
team okay so just give you a summary I
haven't really labored this because I
think I'm I would be preaching to the
choir somewhat cloud is without doubt
for me at least that genuine paradigm
shift I've added education here just
from when I look at the way in which
it's transformed what my kids can do and
now how they're talking to their friends
about of tackling assignments that
they're given it's genuinely
transforming sort of research
capabilities and I would argue that for
those that wish to it can actually
provide a new economic model for the way
in which research is funded not for
everything not for all data but it gives
the opportunity for researchers to make
available their capabilities in a
marketplace in a way that maybe wasn't
so easy before we are offering these
your for research training some you've
taken it some of you don't need it if
you think there are people that do need
it or you want to host some of the
training just let us know the researcher
rewards are a great way of you not
spending any money and getting access to
a lot of compute infrastructure there's
the open invitations every two months we
run these special calls as well such as
we're doing for matlab we've got a lot
of other technical resources the papers
that i mentioned simulation when a
gadget here and lab of things and if you
didn't want to write anything else down
then you know the sort of the catch-all
for everything is as your for research
com that's where you'll find all of this
and lots a lot more okay with that i'll
just say thank you and give you ten
minutes back thank you
you still don't want to write anything
down we have postcards with a ring okay
I was wondering for your research Awards
is there what's the threshold for those
like if I wanted to explore using Azure
as you know data processing platform
versus my own Hadoop cluster versus you
know amazon but I don't really have a
defined research goal that's going to
produce like a paper at the end of it
more like yeah see if this is a
computing paradigm if you guys are
offering better things and then somebody
else is that within sort of the
thresholds and also is there a
limitation on like it must be a
professor or department or Kennedy staff
researchers can PhD students get awards
but then they probably don't need
180,000 hours they probably beat you
know right 5,000 or something yeah yeah
so um okay so so to justify an award
there needs to be something in there or
not I feel like playing around with is
your maybe all right so you're gonna put
some workload on there so you should
just indicate what that is there are a
lot of folks that are doing some pretty
good work on here's a dupe running on
amazon here is it is running on these
other platforms and we actually have a
project with Barcelona supercomputing
Center where they're going into the real
detail of actually for this hardware for
this you know configuration for this
interconnect this is the way for this
type of workload you want to put the
dials because Hadoop has many many
different configuration points so the
maybe something that you suggest where
we go actually that's a dupe of for the
work that we've got you're less likely
to do that if there's something specific
that you're you know I'd like to
evaluate putting this type of workload
on ok that's ok all right we didn't have
to be a tenured professor it has to be
somebody in the university if it's a PhD
student or a postdoc that's awesome
that's really good and they get this as
in a war
what that's actually going to look
really good on their CV thin fact that
they've managed to justify this we would
definitely encourage you know people
within the research groups to sort of
come forward typically you want their
slightly older researcher that that's
maybe been around a little bit he or she
knows how to program not that old no you
want you want somebody that isn't going
to sort of fumble around for the first
six months okay and then realize I'm
gonna got six months left of the award I
mean we can always extend it that's not
a problem we have training passes that
we use for people that take the class
which don't last the full year and the
not as big in terms of footprint but if
you think there's a chance that they're
gonna scale up at some point i would i
would put in for the bigger award if
they don't use it it's not a problem
okay we over allocate all right we were
given this much from the usual business
and we're probably going to give away a
lot more than that on the basis that not
everybody uses everything that's
question so I beleaguered sdsu who
teaches a matlab person now on the
central email saying that she should
maybe approach you a happy and love my
little thing as you have one question I
hope she actually decent a plus so do
you have things that services that are
set up an issue for us getting back
pasture yeah so so you're going to say
no is going to ask you how you open
those suggestions on what should be done
so let me tell you what we've got in
terms of the the educator passes because
they're a little bit different there's
some specific things called educator
passes that we use for people that were
teaching a class where the the faculty
typically faculty member wants to issue
a number of passes to students for a
particular course a particular semester
and they want to be able to go in and
see whether they using them okay so we
have passes like that that we can hit
that have been issued I'm not sure
whether we're still issuing at the
moment but the mechanism is there okay
there there's some funny things go on
though because some people use them in a
very responsible way and some people a
bit less responsible why dilute cluster
and then leave it running yeah there's
going to be a my other questions because
I know there might be this Bailey's you
wanna put some governors in there yeah
yeah yeah we just couldn't beat people
up that's what we do yeah which I'm very
hopeful with but then I'm from England
and that's what we do so this what was
suggestion of hmm it's yours or you can
sign up for free not only 30 days yeah
so that's another company cars com you
can sound for free for one year and this
does these are feedback from some
students I get busy they get homework
stories that I go yeah so is there any
possibility to make that learning period
be longer maybe 60 days or 90 days so at
least they have a chance to learn for
for student and after they learn that we
can maybe give it a research account
yeah this is the so we're providing
feedback to the surety that we don't own
those passes alright so that's the is
your team and you know we're we're also
sort of cognizant of the limitations for
those individual passes okay there are
other forms of passes that would give
them longer access I can't remember but
do you have to put your credit card in
for that other company member yeah I
think you probably do I think so yeah
you do and if you go up the cap you get
charged yeah sure one when you hit the
limit you have to actively unlock it and
in all of you to be charged for it so
that's a slightly different manner play
it smart still I guess get very nervous
right they don't know how they are
getting into mm-hmm already 30 days and
type of scar I thought it does wonder
whether it could be maybe 60 days so
there are few excuses for students to
say and in part that's why for a lot of
the
the the processes that were set up by
another part of our business not that I
particular want to expose the inner
workings of Microsoft to you as one of
the reasons why they went with the
faculty model where they get would would
grant it to a faculty the faculty that
was any issue the passes and those were
you know actually I mean the small but
they're still pretty meaty they go well
beyond what a competitor might have been
offering training pastors are here for
six months no credit card yes so the
training passes that we issue six months
good email put its great feedback and
yes whoop it's one we've had before it's
good to have it reinforced I was
wondering about the hardware thing that
you showed um I look really cool um and
I could see people building that and
maybe integrated in with like the lap of
things and I had sort of two questions
where do we find out more information
about it and the second question is can
you sort of build the same lab of things
kind of infrastructure without having
that requirement of the home ospc there
because that's a much bigger device
costly device whereas these other
smaller things you want to throw out
these sensors and connect them and have
them push data to as your or something
then analyze it that could very easily
scale a lot more than like a PC
somewhere that have doing data
aggregation so the home OS piece of the
lab of things is a requirement for lab
of things okay it acts as that
aggregation point it allows you to
update all right as you control more in
a more sophisticated way the behaviors
of the infrastructure that is deployed
in the setting all right so we went
round that design decision and it's a
very clear requirement that you want to
be able to update drivers you want to be
able to update and you can't do all of
that if if everything's remote and then
you've just got these very dumb clients
okay if however you say no no I don't I
don't want that I won't have this sort
of local aggregation point that
I don't want that you can use gadget
here or other equipment they want to
deploy and use the service bus
infrastructure that there is natively in
the shore and on that point we sat down
again it was the first training that we
did it was down in Brazil and one of the
grant applicants one of our ward
applicants would just put in a huge
request to a funding agency in Brazil
for a whole lot of infrastructure that
they were going to build out and we SAT
with him the day after would run the
training and he was grinning it was just
grinning all right because he was pretty
sure who's going to get his his
application approved from the funding
agency and we just saved him a year
because of the service bus
infrastructure showers gonna build all
about I'm gonna get the money for it but
I don't need to spend in on that because
you've done it all of the message
queuing that that you want handled in an
elegant way we've already got as part of
the service bus because we have lots of
businesses is where you benefit from
that business use of people programming
mobile phone applications that then need
to send messages asynchronously open to
the cloud have something done and then
something sent back out although that's
already there okay you can just
piggyback on that for your scientific
applications you don't have to use lab
of things a lot of things is just a a
more sophisticated way of handling
certain types of work locally typically
clinical people wanting to deploy and
then adjust what they're collecting in a
hub setting
well thank you great thank you